i want to follow up about this armed
march against
the jews that is happening in a small
town in montana
it's moving forward the daily stormer
which is an american
neo-nazi white separatist white
supremacist website
they are planning a march in whitefish
montana
this is where alt-right leader richard
spence's
mother lives now spencer is a white
supremacist
and he is a key player in the alt-right
this is supposedly going to be happening
next week or maybe the following week
but what's interesting is that
even richard spencer himself says the
march is sort of a joke
andrew anglin who's the publisher of the
daily stormer and the organizer of the
march said that montana has very liberal
open carry laws so that his lawyer is
telling him that they can easily march
through the center of whitefish montana
with high-powered rifles and he expects
about 200 people to participate in the
march the march is going to be quote
against jews jewish businesses
and everyone who supports either and
they're going to be bussing in
skinheads from the bay area there's
something funny to me pat about going to
the bay
area to find skinheads to protest jews
in montana doesn't that seem a little
weird
i mean if there's any you know hope for
this story it's that it's getting
attention now
yeah because i think that could inspire
some counter protests if you remember
after donald trump was elected the kkk
scheduled a rally in
north carolina and they ended up not
showing up having to reschedule it there
were much more counter protests in media
than actual
kkk members there so yeah they ended up
backing down the other angle here also
is the fbi confirmed that they're aware
of this
and they're looking into whether any of
this might violate federal law but if
indeed
andrew anglin is right of course you can
you can pro you're allowed to protest we
know that and
if they are legally carrying firearms uh
it's going to be tough to do much about
it unless you can argue that
the the group carrying firearms in a
particular way
is sort of designed to be intimidatory
or whatever
i continue to be interested in the
writing off of anti-jewish harassment
and hate crimes in the united states
many people openly say
listen jews are doing fine we don't
really need to worry about jews but
remember that when it comes to religious
hate crimes in the u.s
jews have been and continue to be the
most victimized group right so not of
all hate crimes
but if we look at religious hate crimes
the number one
victims targets of religious hate crimes
are jews in 2014 for example
about 60 of religiously motivated hate
crimes were against jews
followed by 14 which were anti-islamic
far
far behind anti-semitism i've spoken
about it before
increasingly accepted increasingly
minimized this is a trend that we're
seeing
and from a practical standpoint if
you're looking to protest jews it's kind
of weird to do it in montana i mean i
get that richard spencer's mother lives
there and there's been this whole dust
up about it but
montana has very little diversity never
mind jews there in 2015 there were
reportedly 6 000 jews living in the
entire state
which is 0.77 of the population only
about a third of the national average
jewish population which is 2.2 percent
uh what's the solution ignore it you
suggested maybe you show up with a
counter protest group that's maybe
just as heavily armed although that
seems like a recipe for disaster
yeah and i don't think it's surprising
that they're going to do this in montana
because i think that's where they feel
safe because there's plenty of people
who look like them who you know some of
them may have similar opinions if they
were
going to go to new york city they would
just be in different waters there that's
interesting so on the one hand you'd say
politically it doesn't make sense to
protest where there are so few jews but
in terms of comfort
maybe it makes sense to go where there
are so few jews
uh yeah i wonder what their thought
process is seems mostly connected to
richard spencer's mother being there
although again even he said that the
rally is a joke we'll see if it happens
we'll see what actually
transpires thanks for watching this
video before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the david pakman show
big league as well as expand progressive
activism
go to davidpakman.com donate donations
of any size
are much appreciated